Bu dersimizde seninle hal değişiminin
nasıl gerçekleştiğini ve hal değiştiren
maddelerde ne gibi değişiklikler
olduğunu konuşacağız. Çok kısa bir
şekilde anlatacağım. Hızlı bir şekilde
halledeceğiz. Biliyorum bazılarınız soru
çözüm istiyor benden. Bu ünü T'yi bir
sonraki derste tamamlayacağız. Orada da
ısının nasıl yayıldığını konuşacağız ve
sonrasında da eğer gerçekten
istiyorsanız soru çözümlerini yapacağım
sizler için. Kimileriniz de yazmaya
başlıyor hocam yazılılar gelecek mi?
Yazılı çalışmaları gelecek mi? Siz
sevgili Dokuzlar beni yalnız
bırakmadığınız için hiçbir zaman ben de
sizleri yalnız bırakmayacağım. Elbette
tüm Zed öğretmenleri yine bu son
yazılığınızda sizleri yalnız bırakmadan
hazırlıklarını yapacaklar. Fakat önce şu
son derslerimizi tamamlayalım güzelce.
Sen de anlamadığın yerleri bana muhakkak
sor dakika belirterek yorumlarda
nerelerde takıldığını bana sor ki biz bu
genel tekrarlarımızı ya da
çalışmalarımızı eksiksiz bir şekilde
yüksek verimlilikle tamamlayabilelim.
Hazırsan dersimiz başlasın. Şimdi
aslında biz seninle hal değişimin ne
olduğunu biliyoruz ama bir hatırlayalım.
Normalde maddeler doğada katı, sıvı, gaz
ve plazma halinde bulunabilir ve her
madde kendi içerisinde farklı formlara
geçiş sağlayabilir. Bu da ısı ve
sıcaklıkla, sıcaklık değişimiyle yani
dışarıdan ısı alıp dışarıya ısı vermemle
veya üzerimdeki basıncın etkisiyle
mümkün ancak. Tamam mı? Yani bu
geçişler, formlar arası geçişler
bunlarla mümkün. Şimdi katı bir maddenin
sıvıya dönüşmesi, katıdan sıvıya geçiş
hal değişiminin adı ne? Erime, sıvıdan
katıya geçme, donma. Sıvıdan gaza geçme,
sıvıdan gaza geçtim. Buharlaşma. Aslında
bunu kaynama olarak göreceğiz, hal
değişimi olarak. Fakat her sıvı, her
sıcaklıkta buharlaşıyor. Gaza
dönüşebiliyor. Gazdan sıvıya geçme,
yoğuşma. Şöyle düşünebilirsin. Sıvı
halim gaz halime göre daha yoğundur. Bu
yüzden de bunun adını yani bu buharlaşma
durumunun tam tersini yoğuşma olarak
adlandırırız. Katıdan gaza geçme.
Katıdan gaza geçme bizim için
süblimleşme. Mesela bir naftalin katı
ama etrafa koku yayıyor. Bir gaz
oluşturuyor. Katıdan gaza geçiş
süblimleşme, gazdan katıya geçme kraşma
olarak geçmekte. Biz aslında daha çok
seninle katı, sıvı, gaz arasındaki hal
değişimlerini konuşacağız. Bir de plazma
ve gaz arasında ilişki var. Belki
karşına bir yerde denk gelir. Plazma
dediğimiz durum gazın iyonik
versiyonudur. İyonik versiyonu da
aslında elektriği ve manyetizmayı
etkilendiğini, elektriği iyi ilettiğini
bize göstermiş olur. Bundan dolayı
gazdan plazma haline geçmek iyonlaşma
demek aslında. İyoniz. Plazmadan gaz
haline dönmek deiyonizasyon olarak
geçiyor. Peki bunlar nasıl mümkün
oluyor? Elimde bir buzum var. Ben buza
dışarıdan ısı verdiğimde, onun
sıcaklığını artırdığımda belli bir hal
değiştirme sıcaklığı var. Erime
sıcaklığı 0 S dereceye geldiğinde bu
katı buzum artık sıvı hale geçiyor. Hala
ocağın üstünde olduğunu hayal edelim.
Hala enerji vermeye devam ediyorum. Sıvı
su hali iyice o noktaya geldiğinde
kaynama noktasına geldiğinde kaynama
sıcaklığına 100 st dere dceye
ulaştığında buhar olmaya başlıyor.
Sıvıdan gaza ne oldu? Artık kaynama
gerçekleşti. Yani demek ki biz seninle
bu hal değişimi kısmında bu formlar
arasına geçişte bu dışarıya ısımı
veriyorum, dışarıdan ısım alıyorum.
Bunları konuşmamız isteniyor. Bu hal
değişimi sadece hal değişimi de değil.
Doğadaki bütün mevzuları biz aslında
fizikte inceliyoruz. Çünkü fizik
biliyorsun ki doğa bilimi hatta doğadaki
en temel bilim. Yani biz aslında doğadan
kopya çekiyoruz. Şu su döngüsüne bir
bakalım. Daha çok bunu coğrafyada
konuşuyorsunuz. Su döngüsüne bakalım.
Tamam mı? Deniz ve okyanuslarla çevrili
dünyamız biliyorsun 1örte üç'ü değil mi?
Her yerde suyumuz var. Hatta suyun öz
ısısı yüksek falan diye de konuşmuştuk
önceki derslerde. Buradaki sular, su
molekülleri güneşten gelen bu ışınlar
sayesinde, yüksek enerji sayesinde su
buharlaştı.
Bu yukarıda da hava daha soğuk. Bu sefer
dışarıya bu buharlar enerji vermeye
başladı. E dışarıya buhar enerji verince
gazdan sıvıya dönüşme bir yoğuşma söz
konusu. Hop yağmur oldu. İşte bu bir hep
devir daim şeklinde buharlaşma yoğuşma.
Buharlaşma yoğuşma. Biz buna su döngüsü
diyoruz. Buradan da yola çıkarak aslında
hal değişimi tablomuzu
oluşturabiliyoruz. Saf maddelerde hal
değişimi hal değiştirme sıcaklığında
meydana gelir. Yani elimde katı saf bir
buz var. Bu buz 0 s derecede erir.
Elimde katı başka bir bakır olsun.
Bakırın erime sıcaklığı daha farklı. Her
bir maddenin, her saf maddenin kendine
hastır. Hocam saf madde ne demek? Yani
başka bir molekül eklenmedi. Elimde saf
bir su var. Bu suyun kaynama sıcaklığı
elimdeki saf suyun kaynama sıcaklığı 100
S dce. Ancak tuzlu su olursa bu saf bir
madde değil. Artık başka bir maddeyle
karıştırdım. Anlaştık mı? O yüzden bu
ifade önemli. Saf bir madde hal değişimi
sıcaklığında hal değişimi gerçekleşiyor.
Bunların hepsi de kendine has bir
değerde. Hal değiştirme sıcaklıkları tüm
maddeler için şöyle diyeyim tüm saf
maddeler için ayırt edici özellik. Hal
değişimi sırasında madde ısanmasına ya
da vermesine rağmen sıcaklığı sabit
kalır. Aman Allah değişmez diyor. Yani
hocam nasıl oluyor? Daha yeni siz
dediniz ki elimde bir buz vardı bunu
ocağa koydum. Isı aktarımı
gerçekleşiyor. Ne oldu bu? Katıdan sıvı
hale geçti. Ama siz diyorsunuz ki
sıcaklığı sabit kalır. Bu sadece o erime
veya işte kaynama durumunda, hal
değiştirme durumunda ki birazdan seninle
grafik üzerinden inceleyeceğiz. Hani
dedik ya bizim için her bir saf madde
için ayırt edici özelliktir diye
konuştuk ya. Gel bak değinelim. Mesela
elimde su var. Saf bir sudan
bahsediyorum. Erime ve donma
sıcaklıkları 0 S derecede. Kaynama
yoğuşma sıcaklığı 100 S derecede. Yani
bir buzum var. Bu buz 0 S derecede erir.
Elimdeki su 0 s derecede donar. Anlaştık
mı? Elimde bir suyum var. 100 Sig
derecede kaynar. Elimde bir subaharı
var. 100 S derecede yoğuşur. Buradaki
önemli olan dışarıya ısı veriyorsun.
Dışarıdan ısı alıyorsun. Bu önemli. Bak
oksijenin değerlerine bak. Alkolün
değerlerine bak. Cıvaya bak. Altına
bakota. Her birinin kaynama her birinin
erime donma sıcaklıkları birbirinden
farklı. Çünkü farklı maddelerde bunlar
farklı değerlerde. Burada önemli bir
genel kültür bilgimiz var. Su fokurtulu
bir şekilde kaynıyor. Hepimiz biliyoruz,
değil mi? Kaynama olayı kaynama
sıcaklığında gerçekleşir. Yani asıl hal
değiştirme durumumuz kaynamadır.
Buharlaşma değil. Çünkü buharlaşma her
sıcaklıkta mümkün. Yani elinde bir
bardak var. Bardağın içinde su var. Bir
10 gün bu suyu burada beklet. Herhangi
bir hava sıcaklığında değişiklik olmasa
bile o suyun azaldığını görürsün. Değil
mi? Neden? Kaynadı mı? Fokurdadı mı? I
ama buharlaştı. Çünkü buharlaşma her
sıcaklıkta mümkün. Buharlaşma her
sıcaklıkta meydana gelir. Bu nedenle
çamaşır oda sıcaklığında dahi
kuruyabilir. Kaynama bir enerji
kaynağından sağlanan enerjiyle
gerçekleşirken buharlaşma ortamdan
alınan ısıyla gerçekleşebilir.
Buharlaşma sıvı yüzeyinde gerçekleşirken
kaynama sıvının tamamında gerçekleşir.
Kaynama sırasında sıcaklığımız sabit
kalır. Çünkü kaynama bir hal
değişimidir. Hatta ben sana bak şu
tabloyu da düzelteyim. Buraya yoğuşma
dedik ya. Buharlaşma. Bu kaynama tamam
mı? Çünkü hal değişim durumu kaynamadır.
Buharlaşma esnasında ise sıvı sıcaklığı
azalır. Hani daha yeni şu ifadeyi
kullanmıştık ya buharlaşma sıvı
yüzeyinde gerçekleşir diye. Kaynama her
noktada diye. Buharlaşma sıvı yüzeyinde
neden gerçekleşiyor biliyor musun? Orada
o kinetik enerjiye sahip olan titreşim
hareketi yapan moleküller ne oluyor? gaz
oluyor. Yani sıvıdan gaza geçiş bu
sıvının yüzeyinde gerçekleşiyor ve benim
o hareketli olan kinetik enerjiye sahip
taneciklerim gittiği için geriye kalan
sıvının sıcaklığı azalmış oluyor.
Anlaştık mı? Yani o yüzden buharlaşmayı
hal değişimi olarak almıyoruz. Kaynamayı
hal değişimi olarak alıyoruz. Şimdi
gelelim hal değiştirme ısısı durumuna.
Maddenin hal değiştirdiği sırada aldığı
ya da verdiği ısıya hal değiştirme ısısı
denir. Birimini kalori bölü gram olarak
tanımlarız. Ne olduğunu sana şimdi
söyleyeceğim. Hiç korkma. Birim kütle
başına enerji olduğu için kütleden
bağımsızdır. Hal değiştirme ısısı.
Erime, donma ve buharlaşma yoğuşma
ısıları maddeler için ayırt edici
özellikleri. Hocam daha yeni sıcaklık
demiştiniz şimdi ısı diyorsunuz.
Sıcaklık benim için neydi? Skaler bir
derece ile ifade ettiğim değerdi. Isı
ise bir enerjiydi. Peki nedir bu ısı?
Şöyle iki tane formülümüz var. Q = MC
delta T bir de Q = M x L. İşte hal
değiştirme ısısından kastımız bu L. Yani
senin kütlen ne olursa olsun sen bir
bardak su da ol, bir oda dolusu su ol.
Senin su olarak erime veya donma ısın
aynı. Bunu söylemeye çalışıyoruz.
Kütleden bağımsız. Hocam şu da ısı değil
miydi? Bak bu ısı. Bu hal değiştirme
ısısı. Bu da maddeye has bir değerdir.
Tamam mı? Bunu söylemeye çalışıyoruz.
kalori böl gram diyordu. Q'yu kalori
olarak tanımladık. L M'yi gram olarak
tanımladık. O zaman L''nin birimi ne
oldu? Kalori/ gram oldu. Bir önceki
derste seninle MC ısı sahası veya öz ısı
kavramlarının birimlerini çekmiştik ya.
Burada da bu L dediğimiz ifadenin yani
hal değiştirme ısısının birimini
konuşmuş olduk. Peki hocam ben şunu
anlamadım. Daha yeni dediniz ki ya hal
değiştirirken sıcaklık değişmez falan
filan. Burada çok takıldığını biliyorum.
Şimdi şurayı not al PDF'ine. Tamam mı?
Paylaşıyoruz seninle. Zeduaada
biliyorsun. Notunu aldım, sildim. Gel
seninle şunları konuşalım. Sıcaklık ısı.
Isı değil sana da diyebilir. Böyle bir
grafik karşına gelecek. Ancak diyecekler
ki özdeş ısıtıcıyla yapıyorum. Sen de
diyeceksin ki ya ben 5 dakikada bu özdeş
ısıtıcıdan 5Q enerji aldıysam 10
dakikada 10Q enerji alırım. Yani zaman
veya ısı skalamız burası. Tamam mı? Bu
cepte. Şimdi seninle konuşalım. Elimde
diyelim ki bir maddem var. Bu maddenin
buradaki derecesi -50 olsun. Burası -30
olsun. Sonra 0'a gelmiş olayım. Sonra 20
olsun. Sonra 50 olsun. Bilmiyorum. Tamam
mı? Şimdi konuşacağız. Elimde -50
derecede bir madde var. Bu maddeye ben
dışarıdan ısı veriyorum. Sıcaklığı bu
yüzden arttı. Sonra bir noktaya geldi.
Sıcaklığı sabit kaldı. Hangi noktada
sıcaklığın sabitti? Hal değiştirme. Ha
hocam bak o zaman ne diyeceğiz biliyor
musun? 1 nolu yerde bu maddem katı.
Dışarıda nası verdim katı ya? Q = MC
delta T muhabbetinden bak hocam ne oldu
biliyor musun? Sen bir ısı verdin.
Elinde bir kütlen var. Elinde bu
maddenin ne olduğunu biliyorsun. Öz ısı
değerim var. A ben T1'den T2'ye bir
sıcaklık değişimine sahibim. Tamam
burada benim sıcaklığım değişti dedin.
Şimdi buraya geldiğimde artık o madde
diyor ki ya bak kardeş -30 ne biliyor
musun? Benim bir katı olarak erime
sıcaklığım. Ben artık o dereceye geldim.
Hani mesela şurada demiştik ya erime
donma sıcaklığı da maddeye has bir şey
diye. Buraya gelince bu madden diyor ki
bak diyor hala ocak yanık hala bana
enerji vermeye devam ediyorsun. Ben ne
yapayım biliyor musun diyor artık o
dereceye ulaştığım için ben diyor bu
moleküllerimi böyle titreşim
yaptırmayayım sıcaklığı artmasın. Bu
moleküllerimi birbirinden uzaklaştırmaya
yani katıdan sıvı forma geçmeye gayret
edeyim diyor. Burada artık bu maddem
katı artı sıvı modunda. Burada ne
gerçekleşiyor? erime gerçekleşiyor. Bir
hal değişimi söz konusu. Hal değişiminde
de sıcaklığım sabit gördüğün gibi. Delta
tazmayı düşünsene. Son sıcaklığınla ilk
sıcaklığın aynı. O zaman enerjin 0 mı?
Delta t'den düşün şuraya. Hocam
sıcaklığım değişmedi. 0. E o zaman
enerjim 0. Oysa ocak açıktı. Hala bana
enerji veriyordum. Bak Q1'den Q2'ye
kadar ben bir enerji aldım senden. İşte
burada artık hangi formülü kullanıyoruz
biliyor musun? Q = M x L erime veya L
donma. Çünkü bunlar erime ve donma. Hal
değişim ısıları veya erime donma
sıcaklıkları aynı demiştik. Doğru mu?
Tamam. Şimdi artık burada hal değişimi
söz konusu dedik. Buraya gelince madde
bütün katı versiyonu tamamen sıvıya
dönüştü. Sıvıya döndükten sonra hala
ocak açık. Diyor ki yah o zaman benim
artık sıcaklığım artacak arkadaş diyor.
Bu 3 nolu yerde ben sıvıyım. Artık Q =
MC delta T formülünü kullandım.
Dışarıdan ısalmaya devam ettiğim için
taneciklerim iyice titreşmeye başladı.
Sıcaklığım arttı. Fakat öyle bir noktaya
geldim ki bu sefer bu benim kaynama
durumum. Kaynamaya başladım. Yani hal
değişimi söz konusu. O zaman ben bu
noktada mc delta t yapamayacağım. Çünkü
hal değiştirirken sıcaklığım değişmez.
Sabittir dedim. Geldim buraya. M x L
kaynama, L buharlaşma, L yoğuşma artık
her neyse. Buraya gelene kadar benim
hala ocağım yanıyor. Hala enerji almaya
devam ediyorum. Geldi geldi geldi. Ben
daha yeni sıvıydım ya. Burada sıvı artı
gazım. Buraya geldiğimde tamamen gaza
dönüştüm. Artık burada bir gaz buharı
olarak, bir gaz olarak yolculuğuma devam
ettim. Ve hala ocak açıksa ben ne oldum?
Sıcaklığımı artırdım. Yani hocam ben şu
grafiğe baktığımda bana sıcaklık ısı
veya sıcaklık zaman grafiği
verdiklerinde eğer ki ben şöyle iki tane
sabit yer göreceksem buralar benim
sıcaklığımın sabit olduğunu söylediği
için buralar benim hal değişim
noktalarım. Yani 2 ve 4 nolu yerde hal
değişimi gerçekleşti. Bak şu ana kadar
konuştuklarımızı özetliyorum sana. Yani
sıcaklığımız sabit. Anlaştık mı? Sana bu
yüzden 2 nolu yerde hangi formda? A katı
artı sıvı. Çünkü ben katıdan sıvıya
geçiyorum. Buzdan su oluyorum gibi yorum
yapmanı isteyeceğiz. Bunların hepsini de
sana burada yazdım. Ne mutlu. 1 olduğu
yerde madde katı halde aldığı ısı bak 1
olduğu yerde ne kadar kuber kadar enerji
aldı. Sıcaklık ve kinetik enerjisi
artmakta. Neden? Dışarıdan ısalmaya
devam ediyorum ve taneciklerim
titreşiyor. Fakat 2 nolu bölgede maddem
artık katı artı sıvıda. Çünkü burada bir
sıcaklığın sabit olduğu noktayı gördün.
Kesinlikle hal değiştiriyor dedin.
Aldığısı Q2'den Q1'e kadar olan o mesafe
artık ne kadar bir kalori ise sıcaklığım
sabit çünkü hal değişimi var hocam. Hal
değişiminde artık ben katıdan sıvıya
doğru geçiyorsam benim taneciklerimin
kinetik enerjisi artmıyor. Sıcaklığım
sabit. Ya ne yapıyorum? Uzaklaştırdığım
için bunların birbirlerine göre
konumlarını değiştiriyorum. Potansiyel
enerjilerini artırmış oluyorum. 3 olduğu
yerde artık maddem tamamen sıvı formda.
Aldığı ısı Q3'ten Q2'ye kadar olan yer
buradan sıcaklık ve kinetik enerjisi
artmakta. 4 nolu yerde maddem sıvartı
gaz halde hal değişiminde sıcaklık sabit
kinetik enerjisi sabit potansiyel
enerjisi artmakta. Aldığı enerji de Q4 -
Q3 kadar dedim. 5 nolu yerde madde gaz
halde aldığı Q5 - Q4 kadar şurada var.
Sıcaklık ve kinetik enerjisi artmakta
dedim. Sana çok güzel bir şekilde
özetledim. 1 3 5 no'lu yerde sıcaklık
değişimi olduğu için kel macit diye
kodladığın bu formülden Q = MC delta T.
Yani bu cismin dışarıdan aldığı ısı
miktarı nedir? Kütlesi öz ısısı
biliniyorsa sıcaklık değişimini de sen
bu grafikten gördüysen bu formülü
uyarlayacaksın. Yok hocam hal değiştirme
noktalarındaysam sıcaklığım sabitti.
Herhangi bir şekilde sıcaklığım
değişmediği için mc delta t formülü
anlamsız. O zaman m x l yani l hal
değiştirme ısısı her neyse hangi hal
değiştirme durumundaysan erime mi donma
mı buharlaşma mı kaynama mı yoğuşma mı
ona göre o ifadeyi de yazıp ne kadar bir
kalori sonucunda hal değiştirdiğini
bulabilirsin. Grafiğimiz bundan ibaret.
Böyle bir matematiği söz konusu değil.
Seni matematiğiyle yormayacağız ama
yorumunu isteyeceğiz. Ne dedik? Bu
ısının belli etkileri vardı. İşte
genleşebiliyordum, hal
değiştirebiliyordum. Bir diğeri benim bu
hal değişiminde sıcaklığın dışında bir
etmenim daha var ki o da basınç.
Basıncın hal değişiminin etkisine bir
bakalım. S, Bizmut ve antimon dışındaki
maddelerin erirken hacmi artar. Bu suyun
özel bir durumu söz konusu. Tamam mı? Su
donarken şöyle diyeyim. + 4°'den 0 s DC
gelirken suyun hacmi artıyor. 4
dereceden de daha yüksek sıcaklıklara
10° diyelim, 100 S D diyelim. Buradan da
hacmi artıyor. Normalde biz sıcaklığı
artan bir maddenin hacminin arttığını
biliyoruz. Yani su şurada bir sıkıntısı
yok. Tamam mı? Hiçbir sıkıntısı yok.
Bütün maddelerde sıcaklık artarken hacim
de artar. Yani genleşirsin. Moleküllerin
birbirinden uzaklaşır. Ancak suda öyle
bir özel durum var ki 4 dereceden 0 S
dereceye giderken yani bu neydi bizim
erime donma sıcaklığımızdı. Buraya
giderken de hacm artıyor. İşte bu yüzden
mesela deriz ki cam şişede buzluğa gidip
de su atma. Neden? Çünkü donarken
patlayabilir. Çünkü hacmi artar.
Dolayısıyla ne diyor bak? S, bizmut,
antimon. Şunları biz seninle hiç
konuşmayacağız. Belki kimyada
konuşabilirsin. Dışındaki bütün
maddelerin erirken hacm artar. Bak şimdi
biz burada su için konuştuk. Su donarken
hacmi arttı. Suyun dışındaki tüm
maddeler erirken hacmini artırıyor. Bu
nedenle bu maddelerin üzerinde basıncın
artması ile erime ve donma noktaları
yükselirken basınç arttığında bu
maddeler yani zor eriyor, kolay donuyor
oluyor. Tamam mı? Suyun dışındaki ben
sadece suyu aklımda tutuyorum. Su
erirken hacmi küçülen bir madde. Bak
şimdi buradan buraya gelirken 0'dan 4'e
gelirken bu sefer hacmi küçülecek. Doğru
mu? Hacmi küçülen maddelerde basıncın
artması erime ve donma noktasını
düşürür. Hiçbir şey anlamadım. Şimdi
elimde bir kartopu olsun. Tamam mı? Ben
bu kartopunu sıkayım. Sıktıkça
kartopunun böyle çip şıp şıp damladığını
görüyorum. Normalde bu kartopu buz
olarak hayal edelim. Bu buz 0 s derecede
eriyip su olması lazım. Tamam mı? Ancak
ben sıktığımda 0 S dereceyi beklemeden
çat di erimeye başlıyor. Yani erimesini
kolaylaştırdım.
Donmasını zorlaştırdım. Ben sadece sudan
aklımda tutuyorum. Diğer maddeler bunun
tam tersi diyorum. Bak diğer madde
neydi? Bu maddelerin dışındaki maddeler
erirken hacmi artıyordu. Bu nedenle
maddelerin üzerinde basıncın artması
yani sıkma erime ve donma noktasını
yükseltir. Yani bu maddeler zor erir,
kolay donar demiştik. Ancak buza
baktığında ona bir basınç uygulamam, bir
kuvvet uygulamam onun hemen erimesini
sağladı. Yani kolaylaştırdı erimesini. O
yüzden de erime noktası aslında 0
derecenin altına düşmüş oldu. Yani 0
dereceyi beklemedi ermek için hemencik
eriyi verdi. Veya bunu ben sana şöyle de
örnekleyebilirim. Normalde dağın
tepelerinde hazır bir önceki konunda
basınçla alakalı bir konu olduğu için
dağın tepelerine çıktıkça bana bir
söyle. Atmosfer basıncı ne oluyordu
hocam? Dağın tepelerine çıktıkça bu
basınç, atmosfer basıncı azalıyordu. Dağ
tepelerinde kar var, değil mi? Dağ
tepelerinde kar görüyorsun. Normalde
günlük güneşlik burası. Orada neden kar
görüyorsun? Dağ tepelerinde atmosfer
basıncımız az. Atmosfer basıncımız az
olduğu için hani daha yeni ben topa bir
basınç uyguladığımda kartopuna hemen
erimişti ya kolayca. Basıncı
artırdığımda kolay erime gerçekleşmişti.
Yukarıda dağın tepesinde basınç ne? Az.
O zaman orada artık bu buz nerede eriyor
biliyor musun? 20 S derecede eriyor.
Yani havanın çok çok ısınması lazım ki
erisin. Çünkü basınç az. Ancak ben
basınç uygularsam hemencik kolayca
eridi. 0 S derecede değil -20 S derecede
eridi. Umarım anlatabildim. Suyun
yüzeyindeki basınç arttıkça sıvıdan gaz
haline geçmek zorlaşır. Kaynamak
zorlaşır. Basıncı artırırsak. Mesela biz
100 S derecede su kaynar diyoruz değil
mi? Deniz seviyesinde suyumuz 100 Sig
derecede kaynıyor. O zaman hadi gel yine
dağın tepelerine çıkalım. Yukarılara
çıktıkça basınç azaldı. Burada bana ne
diyor? Basınç arttıkça sıvıdan gaz hale
geçmesi zorlaşır. E ben dağın
tepelerinde o zaman suyu daha çabuk
kaynatırım. Değil 95'te kaynatırım. Bak
tabloya. Rakım 0 metre. Ankara'da 890
Erzurum daha yüksek. Deniz seviyesinden
daha yüksek. O zaman orada su daha çabuk
kaynadı. Aslında sana buradaki bu sözel
bunu anlatmaya çalışıyor. Bak Marif
model bundan ibaret. Burada sana
fizikten bahsetmiyorum. Burada sana
aslında okuduğumuz şeyleri nasıl daha
kolay yorumlarız, nasıl daha kolay
örneklendiririz diye konuşmaya
çalışıyorum. O yüzden Türkçe çok önemli.
Okuma yapmanız çok önemli. Okumak için
illa bir kitabı alıp Dünya Klesesi
okuyacağım diye düşünmeyin. Bilgisayarda
yaptığınız bir araştırma da sizin için
bir okumaktır. Yeter ki okuyun. Yeter ki
okuduklarınızı birine anlatmaya çalışın.
O zaman öğrenme gerçekleşiyor. O yüzden
buradaki ifadeler aslında ders kısa,
notlar kısa ama yoğun ifadeler ya.
Bunların üzerine senin düşünüp kendi
örneklerini bulman lazım. Yoksa ben ahım
şu an bir sürü zekaya sahip olduğum için
değil. Sadece buna vakit ayırıp aa ben
bunu, bu Türkçeyi nasıl daha net kafamda
somutlaştırırım diye işte a -20 0
derecenin altına düşer, kola erir. -20
derecede erir yani diye ifade etmeye
çalışıyorum. dedi ki suyun üzerindeki
basınç arttıkça sıvıdan gaz hale geçmesi
zorlaşır. Yani kaynama noktası yükselir.
Gördüğün gibi İzmir deniz seviyesinde
suyum 100 s derecede kaynarken daha
yüksek seviyelere çıktığımda daha kolay
kaynadı. Daha düşük seviyelerde kaynadı.
Demek ki deniz seviyesine indikçe yani
basınç arttıkça etrafımdaki atmosfer
basıncı arttığı için daha zor kaynadım.
Kaynama noktam yükseldi. Deniz
seviyesinden yüksekteki şehirde atmosfer
basıncı düşük olduğu için suyun kaynama
noktası da düşer diye söyledi. Yani
sadece sıcaklıkla hal değişimi değil
basınç da benim hal değişimi
etkiliyormuş diyebiliriz. Rüzgarlı
havada çamaşırların daha çabuk
kurumasının nedeni bak şimdi rüzgarlı
hava seninle bunu yine bir önceki
ünitede konuşmuştuk. Rüzgar bizim için
neydi? Bir akışkandı. Bir Bernolle
prensibiydi. Ve akışkanlar yüksek
basınçtan alçak basınca doğru hareket
etmekteydi. Tamam. Demek ki rüzgar
varsa, hava hareketi varsa, düşük basınç
var. Tamam. Düşük basınçta ne oluyordu?
Hemen dağın tepelerinden hayal edelim
seninle. Ne oldu? Erzurum'da 95 derecede
kaynama gerçekleşti. Ha o yüzden
rüzgarlı havalarda çamaşırlarımız daha
kolay kurur. Anlaştık mı? Neden? Basınç
az. Rüzgar var, hareket var. Bernolle
bize onu dedi. Hareket varsa basınç
düşüktür dedi. E basınç az. Basınç az
olunca dağın tepesinde suyum daha çabuk
kaynıyordu. Daha kolay kaynıyordu. Yani
buharlaşma ya da kaynama dediğimiz durum
daha kolay oluyordu. Buna bağlı olarak
akışkanların hızının arttığı yerde
basıncın düşmesi ve buna bağlı olarak da
buharlaşmanın kolaylaşması sebebiyledir.
Yani rüzgarlı havalardaki bu çabuk
kuruma durumu da bundan ibaretmiş. Aynı
zamanda saflığımız da bizim hal
değişimimizi etkileyen faktörlerden
biri. Bak basıncı konuştuk. Isı
kavramını konuştuk. Sıcaklığımızdaki
değişimleri konuştuk. Şimdi saflığı
konuşuyoruz. Halşimi sıcaklıklarını
etkileyebilir. Buz içine atılan tuz
buzun erimesini kolaylaştırır. Mesela
şöyle hayal et. Çok karlı bir gün ne
yapıyor belediyeler? Tuz döküyor. Neden?
Çünkü sen tuz döktüğünde sanki bir
basınç uygulamışsın gibi daha kolay bir
erime gerçekleşiyor. Yani normalde bu
buz 0 srat derecede eriyecekken artık
-20'de eriyor. Yani çat diye soğuk
havada bile erime gerçekleşebiliyor.
Suyun içine tuz katıldığında özellikle
bu makarna haşlayanlar varsa aranızda
kaynama gerçekleştikten sonra genelde
mutfak hilesi olarak tri olarak kaynama
gerçekleştikten sonra suya tuz atarız.
Neden? Çünkü tuzlu suyun kaynama noktası
daha yüksektir. Normalde su 100 st
derecede kaynıyor ya. Tuzlu suyu
kaynatmaya kalk 110° derecede olur.
Suyun içine tuz katıldığında suyun
kaynama noktası yükselir. Kaynama
zorlaşır. İşte bu yüzden de biz ne
yaparız? Kaynama gerçekleştikten sonra
su yatarız. Hadi bu da size Dider
Hoca'nın fizik finitonun bir triği olmuş
olsun. Anlaştık mı arkadaşım? Durum
bundan ibaret. Yaptığımız şey bu hal
değişim noktaları her maddenin saflığına
göre değişmekte ve bu hal değişimleri de
aynı zamanda o sıcaklıklar basınç da
değişmekte. Vanim saflığımın buna etkisi
var. Üzerimdeki basıncın buna etkisi
var. Dışarıdan aldığım ısının, dışarıya
verdiğim ısının buna etkisi var diye
yorumlamanı istiyoruz. Burayı birazcık
özetlemen lazım. Burayı birazcık
sindirmen lazım. Çok sözel, çok
karışabiliyor. O yüzden kendi notlarını
da alabiliyor olman lazım. Gelelim ısıl
denge durumuna. Farklı sıcaklıktaki
cisimlerin ısı alışverişi sonunda
ulaştıkları denge sıcaklığına ısıl denge
diyoruz. Zaten ısıyı, sıcaklıkları
birbirinden farklı cisimlerin yüksek
sıcaktan alçak sıcaklığa bir akış olarak
tanımlamıştık. Hatırlıyorsun değil mi?
Yani ısıdan bahsedebilmen için en az iki
şey olması lazımdı ve sıcaklıkları
farklı olması lazımdı. Diyor ki farklı
sıcaklıkta iki cisim var. Bunlar da
birbiriyle ısı alışverişi yapıyorlar.
Son durumda belli bir yeteri kadar süre
geçtikten sonra bunlar artık ısıl
dengeye ulaşıyor. Isıl denge dediğimiz
şey aslında benim diyelim ki sıcaklığım
25° olsun. Senin de 20 S D olsun. Benden
sana bir akış gerçekleşecek. Doğru mu?
Çünkü benim sıcaklığım daha fazla. Biz
bir yerde buluşacağız seninle. İşte o
buluştuğumuz sıcaklık değeri bizim için
denge sıcaklığı. Benim verdiğim ısı
diyelim ki 50 kalori. Senin aldığın ısı
50 kalori. Çünkü enerji, ben bir enerji
veriyorum, sen de o enerjiyi alıyorsun.
Alınan enerji verilen enerjiye eşittir
dedi. Denge sıcaklığı da eğer hal
değişimi yoksa bak çok önemli aramızda
bir değerdir. Anlaştık mı? 25 20 23.5 da
5 s d benim denge sıcaklığım olabilir.
24 s d benim denge sıcaklığım olabilir.
Yani eğer hal değişimi yoksa denge
sıcaklığı senin ve benim sıcaklık
değerlerimizin arasındadır. Hal değişimi
yoksa denge sıcaklığı iki maddenin
sıcaklık değeri arasında yer alır. Denge
sıcaklığı ısı sahası büyük olan maddenin
sıcaklığına daha yakın olur. Bak şimdi
çok güzel. Şimdi diyelim ki elimde iki
tane aynı madde var. Tamam mı? C
maddesi. Bunda şöyle bir kütlem var.
Bunda şöyle bir kütlem var. Bu 30 S D
olsun. Bu 10 S D olsun. Eğer ki bunların
ısı sağları eşit olsaydı yani ikisinin
de m'leri de aynı olmuş olsaydı aynı
madde o zaman bu denge sıcaklığım benim
20 S D olurdu. Tamam mı? Ancak ve ancak
buradaki kütlem daha az. Şuradaki kütlem
daha fazla. O zaman buna daha yakın
olur. Atıyorum 25 S D olur. Anlatabildim
mi ne demek istediğimi? İfade bunu
söylemekte. Denge sıcaklığı kimin ısı
sığası fazlaysa onunkine daha yakın
olur. Eğer aynıysa ısı sığalarımız tam
ortada olur ve hal değişimi yoksa yine
yeniden hal değişimi varsa denge
sıcaklığı T1 veya T2'ye eşit olabilir.
Çünkü biliyorsun ki hal değişiminde
benim sıcaklığım değişmez. Mesela senden
ısı alırım, alırım, alırım. O sırada da
benim sıcaklığım tam hal değiştirme
sıcaklığımdır. Sıcaklığım değişmeyeceği
için senden enerjiyi aldım. Senden
aldığım bu aldığım enerjiyle de ben
kendi moleküllerimi birbirinden
uzaklaştırdım. Sıcaklık, denge sıcaklığı
benim sıcaklığıma eşit olmuş olabilir.
Bunu söylüyoruz. Uzun süre aynı ortamda
ve termal dengede olan tüm maddeler aynı
sıcaklıktadır. Yani şuraya dokunuyorum,
buraya dokunuyorum. Her şey uzun süre
aynı ortamdaysa aynı sıcaklıkta. E hocam
dokunduğumda bazen farklı hissiyatlar
oluyor. Onu bir diğer derste
konuşacağız. İşin özü buydu. Şuradaki
soruları cevaplayalım seninle hemen.
Eşit kütleli erime sıcaklığında ABC katı
maddelerinden özdeş ısıtıcılarla belli
bir süre ısıtıldıktan sonra en çok A en
az C maddesinin erittiğini gözlemliyor.
Buna göre bu maddelerin erime ısılarını
kıyaslayınız. Eşit kütleli hepsi. Tamam
mı? M la M LB M LC diyelim. Özdeş
ısıtıcılarla belli bir süre. Yani
hepsine aynı enerjiyi verdik. Bak
arkadaşım hepsine aynı enerjiyi
veriyorum. Ancak en çok A maddem erimiş.
Tamam mı? benden istediği bunların
m'leri de aynı. En çok A maddem
eridiğine göre aynı enerjide demek ki
A'nın erime ısısı B'ye göre C'ye göre en
küçük olanı ki benim verdiğim ısı bunu
eritmeye yetmiş olsun. Ancak C'ye bak. C
maddesi en az erimiş. Ya aynı miktar
ısıyı verdim. 100 kalori verdim. Sen A
olarak hepsini erittin. C hepsini
eritemedi. Neden? Demek ki onun L
değeri, hal değişimi, ısısı daha
büyükmüş ki onu eritmekte zorlandım.
Aynı enerjide diye yorumladım. Hemen şu
hal değişimlerine bakalım. Verilen
örneklerde hangi hal değişimi
gerçekleşmektedir diye sordu. Şimdi
kestiğimiz karpuzu güneşe bırakmaz.
Karpuzu güneşe bırakınca karpuz soğuyor.
Nasıl mümkün oluyor? Hazır mısın?
Aslında karpuzun içindeki sıvılar, sular
gaza dönüşüyor. Sıvıdan gaza dönüşme bir
buharlaşma. Kaynama gerçekleşmiyor. Bak
buharlaşma gerçekleşiyor. Tamam mı? Yani
kaynama bir hal değişimiydi. Burada bir
anlık buharlaşma gerçekleşiyor.
Buharlaşmada da ne demiştik?
Sıcaklığımız azalıyor. Çünkü o yüzeydeki
kinetik enerjisi yüksek olan moleküller
bir anda gitmiş oluyor. Yani benim var
olan moleküllerimin kinetik enerjisi
azaldı. Kinetik enerjinin ortalama
değerine de sıcaklık demiştik.
Sıcaklığımız azaldı. Bu yüzden de
karpuzu kesip belli bir süre güneşte
bekletince karpuz soğur diyoruz. Çok
güzel bir örnek. Kolonya dökünce
elimizin ferahlaması. Kolonya sıvı.
Sıvıdan yine bir gaza dönüş söz konusu.
Doğru mu? Sıvıdan gaza dönüş. Yine
burada bir kaynama değil de buharlaşma
gerçekleştiği için sıcaklığım azaldı
derim. Terlediğimde vücudumun
serinlemesi. Terleme olayında ne
yapıyoruz? Yine yeniden serinlediğimiz
için aslında sıcaklık azalıyor. O zaman
sıvıdan gaza geçiş, su gaza dönüşüyor.
Bu yüzden anlık olarak serinleme
hissiyatı oluşuyor. Yazın soğuk su
koyduğumuz bardağın buğlanması. Bak
burada gazdan sıvıya dönüş söz konusu.
Gazdan sıvıya dönüş benim sıcaklığımın
arttığını söyler. Kar yağınca havanın
sıcaklığının artmasın değil mi? Bunu
hepimiz biliriz ya. Kar yağdı da hava
yumuşadı deriz mesela. Neden? Kar
yağınca ne oldu arkadaşım? Hemen
düşünelim. Gaz molekülleri katıya
dönüştü. Bak gazdan katıya bir dönüşme
söz konusu oldu. Yani orada soğuk hava
molekülleri katıya dönüşmüş oldu. Bu da
yine benim sıcaklığımın artmasını
sağladı. O yüzden hava yumuşadı deriz.
Ateşli hastaya ıslak havlu ne oluyor?
Anlık olarak sıvıdan gaza dönüşme
gerçekleştiği için sıcaklığımız
azalıyor. Özellikle bunların hepsini
buharlaşma olarak değerlendirmeni
istiyorum. Toprak testide suyun soğuması
toprak testiye konulurdu köylerde veya
eski vakitlerde yine yeniden. Neden?
Oradaki sıvı yine anlık olarak
buharlaşıyor. Sıvı gaza dönüşüyor.
Dolayısıyla sıvı gaza dönüştüğü için ne
olduğunu söyleyebilirim. Sıcaklığın
azaldığını söyleyebilirim. Bu yüzden de
suyum soğudu diyebilirim. Bunlar en
gıcık hal değişimi sorularıydı bu arada
haberin olsun. Diğerleri hep bildiğin
katının sıvı ya sıvının gaza
dönüşmesiyle alakalı bildiğin hal
değişimleri. Buradakileri ben sana
yazılıda sorarım. Hangi hal değişimi
var? Sıcaklığım ne oluyor diye konuşmanı
isteyebilirim. Haberin olsun. Mesela
yazın soğuk su koyduğumuz bardağın
buğulanması. Bunu mesela sana şey olarak
sorabilir öğretmenin. Mesela kışın
arabaya bindiğinde o buğuları görürsün.
Aslında o bunun sebebi de o soğuk hava
molekülü sıvılaşıyor. Bunu yaparken de
ortama ısı veriyor. Isı verdiği için de
ortam ne olmuş oluyor? Sıcaklığını
artırmış oluyor gibi yorumlayabilirsin.
Bunlar dediğim gibi en gıcık hal
değişimi sorularıydı. Hemen şu soruya
bakalım. A ve B maddelerini vermiş.
Sıcaklık ısı vermiş. Başlangıçta katı
halde olan özdeş ısıtıcılarla ısıtılan
AB sıcak katılarına ait sıcaklık ısı
grafiğini verdik. A ve B aynı madde
olabilir mi? Bir kere zangk diye. Hayır
de lazım. Nedenini bir durdur yaz. Neden
değildir. Söyle hocam. Belki ben öz
ısıyı konuşacağım. Hocam şunu
konuşacağım gibi bir şeyler
diyebilirsin. Benim çat diye diyeceğim
şey burası katıydı. Burası katı artı
sıvı. Katı. Katı artı sıvı. Bunların
erime sıcaklıkları
t erime diyelim farklı olduğu için
bunlar asla aynı madde olamazlar. Çünkü
biliyoruz ki bu saf maddeler eğer
aynıysa yani aynı sudan bahsediyorsam
saf bir sudan bahsediyorsam elimde ne
olursa olsun ikisinin de kaynama
sıcaklığı 100 S D olacak. Ne kadar
miktarda olursa olsun. Ancak burada
farklı sıcaklıklar olduğu için buna TB
diyelim buna TA diyelim. Bunların erime
sıcaklıkları farklı. Erime
sıcaklıklarının farklı olması demek bu
maddelerin aynı olmaması demek. Bu
maddelerin eşit kütlede erime ısılarını
kıyaslamam istendi. Bağışta katı halde
olan bak şimdi eşit kütlede erime
ısılarını. Erime ısısı deyince aklıma
hal değişimi geliyor. Hal değişimini de
şöyle yazıyordum. Şimdi arkadaşım
seninle şuna bakalım. Buradaki B'nin
enerjisini yorumlayalım. Gel bir de
A'nın enerjisine bakalım. A ve B'nin QA
değerinin QB değerinden daha büyük
olduğunu söylerim. Demek ki A'nın erime
ısısı B'den daha büyükmüş diye
yorumlayabilirim. Tabii bu grafikte
verilen şeyin de başlangıçta katı halde
olan özdeş ısıtıcılar dedi. A ve B
burada özdeş miktar demesi lazım ki ben
kütlelerin de aynı olduğunu söylemiş
olayım. Hal değişiminden yararlanarak.
Hal değişim sürelerini kıyasla dedi. Bak
arkadaşım daha yeni sana derste ne
dedim? ısı yerine zaman da yazabilirsin.
Hangisi daha uzun süre kaloriye ihtiyaç
duydu? Grafikte baktığında QA. O zaman
demek ki özdeş ısıtıcıyla daha fazla
enerji veriyorsam demek ki A'ya
harcadığım zaman daha fazladır demeni
istiyoruz. Anlaştık mı? Çok güzel bir
soruydu. Bu grafik sorularından korkma.
Sana ne veriliyor? Hal değişimi ile
alakalı neler soruluyor? Bunları
rahatlıkla cevaplayabilirsin. Hal
değişimi önemli bir kısım. Eski
müfredatta da şu anki Marif modelde de
bizim için güzel şaşırtıcı soruları
mevcut. Ben bu dersten sonra sana bir de
ısının iletim yollarından bahsedeceğim.
Ancak sen istiyorsan ki hocam ben soru
çözümü istiyorum hem gerek klasik gerek
şıklı sorular görmek istiyorum diyorsan
gerçekten bana yorum yazmanız lazım
arkadaşlar. Beni motive etmeniz lazım.
Belki kimileriniz biliyordur. Bir sağlık
problemiyle uğraşıyorum babamın. Eee çok
şükür ameliyatını tamamladı. Evine
geçti. Ancak gerçekten bu sancılı
süreçte beni ayakta tutan ve derslere
bağlayan, bu videoları çekmemi sağlayan
tek şey aranızdan birkaç öğrencimin
yazdığı o yorumlar. O yüzden bunun ne
kadar büyük bir motivasyon kaynağı
olduğunu size tekrar hatırlatıyorum.
Eğer soru çözümü de istiyorsanız burayla
alakalı sayısal işlemler yok ama belki
öğretmenleriniz sayısal da soruyor. Bana
gerekli yorumları yazarsanız ben de ona
göre diğer konuyu da tamamladıktan sonra
üniteyi bitirdikten sonra böyle karışık
bir soru çözümü hazırlayabilirim. Diğer
derste görüşünceye kadar kendine iyi
bak. Aklına takılan olursa da dakika
belirterek yorumlara muhakkak yaz.
Öptüm. Görüşürüz. Bay bay.